if you were able to look through the
perspective of a person who thinks the
world is flat you would see this the
North Pole is right here in the center
the continents splayed out over this
plane and here on the edges you'd run
into a hundred and fifty foot wall of
ice guarded by NASA employees with guns
and how far that ice goes outward and
when people try to go down there they
get turned away at gunpoint and put in
prison the heavens are a dome that arcs
over the flat earth the Sun the Moon the
Stars they're all just little balls of
light in the sky that move around just
above the Earth's surface there are
loads of people who actually believe
this YouTube channels and Facebook pages
you see hundreds of thousands of
followers Google searches for the term
Flat Earth proof over time look like
this it's become incredibly popular and
recently a poll showed that only 84% of
Americans agree with the statement I
have always believed the world is round
84% and if you're 18 to 24 that's more
like 66% which is like dangerously close
to half what is going on here
now the North Pole is the center of a
deep ocean whereas a South Pole is a
center of a high plateau which averages
seven or eight thousand feet in altitude
this is frustrating and what's even more
frustrating is every time I try to look
into this and understand it all I see is
coverage of like flat earther
conventions and like interviews with
these people we absolutely know for a
fact this ain't it
these interviews are interesting but I
want to understand like how someone with
a thinking brain can actually get behind
this
what is this actual belief where does it
come from and how do potentially
millions of people believe that the
earth is flat the water is completely
flat so as far as we can see in as far
as we've measured and the horizon is
completely flat I'm in Mexico now I've
been sitting on the beach reading
everything there is to read about the
history of people who believe the earth
is flat there's one thing that I just
had to try for myself this is a simple
experiment anybody can conduct to
determine definitely that earth is flat
where have a spirit level you take it on
the plane in filius if they found this
hardware store bought myself a level
Gadhafi's amigo and i'm bringing it with
me on the airplane I'm gonna do some of
this empirical science myself if you are
to fly on a non rotating earth please
explain what kind of experience will a
pilot
the logic goes that if the earth is
round and I'm flying thousands of miles
which I'm about to do then the airplane
will have to be tipped a little bit the
whole time in order to make it around
the curvature of the earth the plane
should be constantly dipping its nose
forward in order to compensate for the
curvature
I would be able to see the tilt of the
airplane if I put my newly purchased
level on the tray table in front of me
I'm going to take my spirit level onto
the plane if my tool shows me that the
plane is totally leveled that's proof
that the earth is flat let's go see what
happens somebody explain to me duty-free
buy perfume why is it so much perfume it
in duty-free
[Music]
four hours on an airplane and I'm back
my little level experiment worked
wonderfully the bubble stayed nice and
Center turns out the plane was not
dipping its nose in order to make it
around the earth this is explained by
the basics of gravity and physics this
video is not a debunk of Flat Earth
theory this that doesn't need to happen
that it shouldn't need to happen what
this is is my fascination with the fact
that there is lots of people but for
this way a nonzero number of humans who
think the world is flat and they work
really hard to prove it I want to
understand what sorts of tools are being
used to prove the world is flat so here
we go wonder if I can get some really
dramatic like conspiracy theory lighting
going on here
seeing all the evidence what if the
earth actually is flat the plane wasn't
tipping the level was flat okay I'm
kidding let's get into this I've been in
the winds learning about the Flat Earth
experience what people believe and why
and where it all came from and here's
what I've learned number one flat
earthers have become a thing just in the
past couple hundred years so by like 205
BC you've got these really smart Greek
people making experiments that are like
observing a globe shaped earth over the
next several centuries eventually this
would just become the widespread thing
among anyone who was doing
experimentation on the world and
eventually nobody believed the earth was
flat even in like the medieval times
like it was a consensus that the earth
was a globe
so in short flat earthers weren't a
thing during this time even though
literally in elementary school I was
taught that Christopher Columbus and
like his voyage was somehow to prove
that the earth was round or maybe it was
flat and that there was like some
debater on that that's actually a total
legend and I have no idea why I was
taught that in elementary school how did
that happen I actually genuinely curious
like how did that happen the fact is
Christopher Columbus the Catholic Church
the Spanish patrons no one thought the
earth was flat but then they became a
thing any sort of flat earther movement
didn't actually come around ironically
until science was really starting to
heat up during the mid 1800s a huge
amount of scientific breakthrough was
happening the scientific method was
taking off and huge breakthroughs in
biology physics anatomy and mathematics
we're taking place but at the time there
were also people who were becoming
uncomfortable with how advanced
scientific methods were getting these
guys would like hold on a second you
have all these fancy new tools to
inquire into the world and to understand
reality but these tools are getting like
too sophisticated and too abstract and
theoretical they're becoming too
disconnected from like what
I can see and understand and touch and
feel they wanted to bring science back
to what it had been for a really long
time which is that like a person goes
out uses simple tools like a telescope
to look at the world and to make
conclusions about how the world works so
it's the 1800s science is like having
its time and you have these guys usually
from like the US and the UK who want to
throw out this growing body of like
amazing advancements in science and they
start to do experiments here's what
those experiments look like so it's the
summer of 1838 England up in the county
of Cambridgeshire which literally sounds
like a place in the Lord of the Rings so
it's the summer of 1838 and the atom had
just been discovered and the Doppler
effect is like being fleshed out and
then you've got this guy his name is
Samuel Rowbotham but he goes by the
pseudonym parallax which is actually a
pretty dope name like if I were a DJ I
would totally go with like parallax
anyway
parallax decides even though all this
science is happening he thinks it's time
to reopen up the debate about whether or
not the earth is a globe which was like
literally settled thousands of years
earlier but he's like no let's do and he
finds this canal system that is
incredibly straight this canal goes on
further almost ten kilometres like six
miles of just a straight line this guy
says if the earth is a globe and people
say it's twenty five thousand miles in
circumference then if I look at it's
straight line after the first mile the
curvature of the earth would mean that
the canal would now be eight inches
lower after two miles it would be 32
inches lower
after three miles 72 inches lower
meaning like six feet almost two meters
and so on so he thinks eventually the
dip from the curvature of the earth
would be so great that you could easily
observe it
so he gets in the water he puts a
telescope right above the surface of the
water
and then puts a boat on the canal with a
1 meter tall post on it so what he wants
to see is if the earth is curved if it's
a globe this post will start to
disappear over the horizon so he does it
the boat goes away it goes the entire
six miles of the canal and it stays in
sight the entire time it doesn't dip
over the horizon and he's stoked he's
like man I just proved that the earth is
flat and I did it with a telescope and a
boat like screw you science like I'm
making breakthroughs right here in
Cambridgeshire and then he writes this
book where he flushes out this
experiment and several others that he
does but wait this experiments like kind
of legit right it adds up like his
numbers were all correct about the
circumference and the tip of the
curvature why didn't it dip like why was
the boat still inside there's nothing
wrong with this experiment I relaxed top
that great name maybe he was onto
something no no this is stupid this is
like a third grade science experiment in
your backyard this experiment doesn't
take into account how the natural world
actually works and how light behaves and
refracts based on the different air
densities this is like stuff that people
already figured out and like parallax is
sitting there getting wet in a canal
like trying to observe this on it as
know it this does not prove anything but
parallax didn't want to hear any of this
didn't want to talk about atmospheric
refraction and air density and how light
behaves in different media too
complicated to abstract
you can't touch and feel that stuff
instead parallax sees science and
observing reality as a much simpler task
in his book he says nature speaks to us
in a peculiar language in the language
of phenomena she answers at all times
the questions which are put to her just
like go out and like put a question to
mother nature and she'll answer it as
scientific methods become more
sophisticated they become harder for you
and me to understand parallax and his
canal experiments are
reaction to all of this they are a call
for a simplification of scientific
methods and a return of the senses as
the primary force for understanding
reality he called his method of
reduction as pseudoscience the zetetic
method he says that honesty of thought
is to look at truth in the face not the
side face but the full front like just
like look at it go out and observe it
for yourself
he was among several scientists and
mathematicians at the time who were on
this train of let's use really
simplified reductionist math and science
to prove that the earth is actually flat
this argument of the Flat Earth
flickered for a little bit in the 1800's
gained a little bit of traction but then
eventually it died out until just a few
years ago refused to be another
vegetable pseudoscience garbage will to
me be unacceptable anyone would ask to
see you don't have to be susceptible
dispose of the globe in the nearest
waste receptacle there's no curvature to
this earth there is no motion to this
earth you just accept the globe model
with no understanding of the flat and no
clear evidence for the ball earth do you
see the problem there flat earthers are
back and their methods are very similar
to what parallax was doing in the 1800s
and this is data this is repeat
full observable measurable if you take
the time to learn you will change your
mind there's there's no doubt the only
reason people think they live on a
spinning ball is willful ignorance
they're still zooming into horizons but
now they have hordes of visual stuff to
play around with
they now have airplanes they now have
satellite imagery to play around with
they now have the moon landing to
dissect and now they're taking levels
onto airplanes like I did your plane
can't go upside down here's the thing
globehugger like the flat earthers in
the 1800's the flat earthers today want
to use their own intuition and senses to
understand reality and in the process
they reject and ignore the huge body of
science that we all live with today so
people that have physics degrees
astronomy degrees he got their degree by
regurgitating what their teacher of the
books told them instead of trigonometry
and telescopes and canals the flat
earthers today use videos and photos
circulated on the internet the has a
muscle equidistant projection map that
the usgs actually uses is the Flat Earth
map wait did he just say as a thermal
equidistant projection that's like my
favorite projection is that the Flat
Earth map don't with me and projections
I take them very seriously in true
internet fashion this new current
movement of flat earthers has become
just a bunch of bumper sticker type
assertions and images that are really
easy to share just like parallax's
experiments these methodologies
completely ignore the way the natural
world is observed to work by like
thousands of years of scientific
consensus but if you go to the faq page
of the Flat Earth Society you'll see
what they're after here they believe
that evidence is quote relying on your
own senses to discern the true nature of
the world around us
that's the best evidence and in that
vein that's how these people are doing I
mean so in the physics world today do
they not understand that convex lenses
or fisheye lenses or GoPro add a
distorted view so what have I learned
from all of this
from my understanding the flat earther
movement whether from the 1800s or today
on the Internet is actually not totally
about the shape of the earth this
movement has a much broader message
built into it there's a reason why 1984
is like in the Canon of the flat earther
movement 1984 has nothing to do with the
shape of the earth what it does have to
do with is being skeptical of big
institutions that are probably watching
you that are probably controlling your
life that are probably feeding you bad
information to retain power we're not
crazy we're just secret lies here's the
thing most of the knowledge we have
about the natural world and the universe
we've never seen we've never seen
exoplanets or the deep space telescopes
that tell us so much about our universe
instead we read about this stuff we
benefit from its findings we pay our
taxes to fund more of it science is like
a tall tower and each individual
researcher and institution adds a little
brick to that Tower each brick resting
on the one below it no one person sees
or understands all of the bricks
instead we have a system of debate
review scrutiny that only allows the
most accurate information to be added to
the tower and honestly I don't think
humans are well suited to adapt to this
very impersonal way of understanding the
world we have evolved over millions of
years with our senses as our main driver
of survival and now we live in a society
that is run by big systems and
impersonal institutions that we will
never touch and feel much less
understand and that's why we have people
who believe the world is flat despite
conclusive evidence to the contrary this
belief is a proxy for a much larger
paradigm that mistrusts anything that
you can't touch and feel and so yeah I'm
really sad that only 84 percent of
people can say with certainty that
they've always believed that the world
as a globe and that's 64 percent
or younger people only 64% of people
like that that just blows my mind and
it's incredibly sad but despite this
belief this movement these conventions
this total lunacy science will continue
to do its thing it will continue to go
out observe the world with these amazing
tools that we have come back debate it
and add to this tower of knowledge that
helps us see the world as it really is
I want to thank Skillshare for
sponsoring this video
Skillshare is this amazing giant
repository of online tutorials where you
can learn everything you can imagine
from photography to design to
illustration to character animation to
filmmaking to entrepreneurship all the
things and you get unlimited access to
the entire library if you subscribe you
get two months free to Skillshare if you
click the link in my description you
should check out this course on the
fundamentals of photo editing photo
editing is truly a craft and with a
little bit of training you can
dramatically change how your photos look
and feel both from just simple mobile
photography all the way to advanced
professional photography having these
fundamentals in your toolkit will help
you make better images so click the link
in the description to sign up for two
months for free like you literally don't
pay any money for two months you can
test it out and see if you like it after
that it think it's like less than ten
bucks a month if you subscribe to the
yearly which ten bucks like ten bucks to
have access to this giant repository of
tutorials is like a no-brainer to me so
I love Skillshare I love internet
learning go check it out thank you for
watching this video and I'll be back
soon with some more stuff see ya
you
[Music]